wenn es geht in einem satz was ist
typisch markus söder einer class größen
waren angeberei showtalent man sieht ja
an seiner weiß-blauen maske die ja
überall trägt also er trägt ja nicht das
modell aus dem csu fanshop sondern eine
sonderanfertigung und die rauten auf
seiner maske sind natürlich größer als
sie haben gerade acht seiten haben schon
gesagt titelstory über markus söder
geschrieben wissen sie ob der kanzler
kann oder nicht
und natürlich weiß ich ob er kanzler
grund oder nicht also ich würde sagen er
könnte es aber er wäre kein guter
kanzler für deutschland also warum aus
ihrer sicht im markus hörer kann krise
das hat ja markus blume auch gerade
gesagt und dann gebe ich ihm recht
markus müller kann krise und ich halte
ihn auch für den stärksten
kanzlerkandidaten in der riege der
anderen kanzlerkandidaten aber warum
weil die anderen so schwach sind und
weil er wahnsinniges glück hatte der
markus söder nämlich dass der zeitgeist
ihm zu trägt derzeit ist autoritär
geworden er ist kälter geworden und der
zeitgeist ruft nach einem starken mann
und also jetzt der starke start war
schon immer das spielfeld der union und
markus söder ist definitiv gerade der
stärkste stürmer auf dem platz aber nur
weil jemand krise kann nur weil jemand
die pflicht kann heißt das nicht
automatisch dass er die türken dass er
kanzler kann und ich hab da schon starke
bedenken zum einen weil der politik
macht mir so ein möbelpacker der
interessiert sich auch nicht dafür was
in den kisten vor ihm liegt er trägt sie
halt weg ja markus stöger ist der starke
mann
das kann er gut und er hat natürlich
auch so
er ist ein wahnsinniger opportun ist ja
und er ist ein populist und zwar ein
sehr gerissen ab open ist das macht aber
nicht besser